[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Julien bloutin
sous-directeur adjoint du pôle gestion
et valorisation du patrimoine des
Yvelines on va parler ensemble de la
troisième édition de la Garden Party le
17 juin prochain au domaine de Madame
Élisabeth à Versailles bonjour bonjour
alors la Garden Party c'est donc le 17
juin quels sont les objectifs de cet
événement très simple proposer aux
yvelinois et aux habitants
d'Île-de-France un événement gratuit sur
une thématique donc Flower Power et une
journée voilà en espérant qu'on est le
soleil avec nous une journée en famille
pour découvrir des groupes Yves les noix
mais pas que dans un cadre et une
ambiance exceptionnelle on va revenir
justement tout au long de cette émission
sur l'organisation sur la programmation
de cet événement vous l'avez dit
l'événement est gratuit est-ce qu'il y a
là une ambition de permettre à tous de
participer à un événement sans se
soucier du budget c'est exactement ça la
volonté de notre président Pierre B
c'est de proposer donc aux Yvelines
Linois un événement mais sous le sens du
service public donc notre priorité et
notre enfin notre propriété pour cet
événement c'est que c'est soit gratuit
et accessible à tout le monde non une
petite sieste sur réservation bien
entendu pour avoir le billet coupe-file
justement comment ça va se s'organiser
est-ce qu'il y a des bénévoles qui
seront qui sont là pour vous aider à la
mise en place par exemple ou des
services civiques alors oui
effectivement donc c'est l'ensemble de
la sous-direction gestion et
valorisation du patrimoine qui se met en
ordre de marche qui représente à peu
près une dizaine de personnes donc on va
être mobilisé pour pour encadrer
l'événement pour conseiller les
visiteurs et pour pour faire en sorte
que tout se passe au mieux bien entendu
la protection civile sera présente pour
assurer tout petit accident sur sur le
lieu d'événement alors l'événement
commence à midi et se termine à 23h30
faut-il obligatoirement venir pour midi
ou les visiteurs pardon peuvent venir un
peu n'importe quand dans la journée vous
pouvez me dire quand vous voulez
l'ouverture c'est midi voilà jusqu'à
23h23h30
l'accès est libre voilà en fonction de
vos plannings du week-end vous venez
quand vous voulez l'événement s'inspire
des festivals flower power des années 70
pourquoi ce choix pourquoi flower power
avec Madame Allard donc Laura Allard qui
la principale organise de l'événement ou
alors garder un peu ce qui se passait
sur Coachella cette année et cette
ambiance un peu hippie un peu flore
power bon on s'est dit au lieu de
dépenser un billet d'avion à 1000 € et
de se payer un festival aux États-Unis
pourquoi pas proposer dans une moindre
mesure bien entendu un festival sur
cette même thématique cette même
ambiance à Versailles donc c'est pas ce
on va pas dire se plaquer finalement au
festival Coachella mais c'est prendre un
petit peu l'idée pour permettre dans les
Yvelines tout à fait puis on aimait bien
cette ambiance
voilà un peu des années hippies et cette
ambiance décontractée ou voilà on a
envie un peu de joie de sourire
pour pour les Yvelinois et pour les
habitants en Île-de-France on va
justement parler de la programmation et
de ce qui sera proposé lors de cette
garden party des concerts et des
animations seront proposés une dizaine
de groupes seront présents parmi eux the
mocking rosters photographe ou encore
Moon comment artistes ont été
sélectionnés alors on travaille avec les
salles de concerts-villoise
comme la clé des champs la clé
Saint-Germain ou encore jolie prod voilà
pour essayer de dénicher les les futurs
pépites
donc qui font voilà on est sur une
diversité de musique on va de la pop
pour on a un DJ
on a du jazz enfin voilà on a travaillé
que ces salles de spectacle pour
vraiment avoir le les meilleurs artistes
au sein de notre événement donc une
sélection très éclectique finalement
tout à fait est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter justement quelques artistes
qui seront qui seront présents oui bah
je vais commencer par ceux qui viennent
plus loin coralien qui nous vient de
Belgique voilà qui qui vient de sortir
son premier album et qui monte en
puissance donc ça nous fait très plaisir
qui soit présent je peux vous parler de
Mira aussi qui est au niveau rap un peu
soul voilà une une future je pense star
montante dans ce domaine où albertaouil
qui sur Instagram fait des super vidéos
où il a commencé à remixer en fait des
tubes connus de tous et maintenant à
proposer ses propres musiques
aussi caravane jazz quinté qui vient des
Yvelines avec cette ambiance jazz
dynamique qui va mettre du peps à
l'événement vous l'avez dit la plupart
des artistes des groupes qui seront
présents viennent des Yvelines ou d'îles
de France là aussi il y avait une
volonté de valoriser justement le les
artistes d'Île-de-France et des Yvelines
oui dans chaque événement qu'on organise
à l'instar du comptoir de Noël en
décembre on essaie de prioriser voilà
les artistes locaux
on manque pas de talent donc autant
faire avec eux lors de cette journée des
animations seront également proposés
notamment des ateliers créatifs
qu'est-ce qui sera proposé lors de ces
ateliers créatifs alors ça les ateliers
créatifs donc une partie sont organisées
par nous-mêmes un bénévole agent du
département autour de la création
florale et on va voir aussi deux
ateliers plus artistiques
avec deux artistes Lord vilmore autour
de la peinture et autour de l'expression
graphique les visiteurs pourront
également participer à des animations
sportives comme des cours de Zumba ou de
volley-ball encore une fois ces
activités sont-elles ouvertes à tous
alors oui pour la zumba ouvert à tous
sur inscription je vous conseille de
vous dépêcher d'aller sur le site
internet pour réserver votre place en ce
qui concerne le volley-ball là en fait
c'est en libre-service au niveau du
matériel donc le premier arrivé premier
servi comme pour les jeux en plein air
il y a des jeux en plein air qui seront
à disposition des visiteurs voilà des
points de restauration aussi alors quels
sont les jeux justement qu'on pourrait
qu'on pourrait faire mais il me semble
que j'ai vu du molky par exemple c'est
l'occasion de découvrir ou de jouer au
Mölkky avec d'autres personnes de faire
des rencontres aussi c'est possible très
simplement vous présenter à l'accueil
vous laissez votre carte d'identité et
on vous prête le matériel nécessaire
pour jouer au molky pour jouer au
volley-ball au badminton voilà l'idée
c'est que ça soit vraiment une fête
accessible et donc on prête le matériel
nécessaire et évidemment vous pouvez
jouer avec d'autres personnes sur la
manifestation vous mettez également des
points de restauration en place
qu'est-ce qui sera proposé aux visiteurs
est-ce que la Garden Party ce sera
également l'occasion de faire un voyage
culinaire mais de manger local en même
temps les deux
premièrement autour de la glace des jus
de fruits frais en espérant qu'il fasse
très chaud le 17 juin une partie burger
avec les burgers d'Émilie et on a essayé
de rendre un de proposer un voyage
culinaire avec la jeune entreprise
taiban et sa chef n'ont pas Channing
notamment qui va proposer un bo-bun
revisité façon thaïlandais et le
traditionnel pad thaï la Garden Party
doit être avant toi un rendez-vous
familial et bon enfance selon vous c'est
en tout cas votre votre ambition alors
c'est l'ambition de l'événement et c'est
l'ambition du domaine de ma isabeth
c'est un parc qu'on appelle de quartier
destiné aux familles principalement et
donc dans la continuité on espère que
cet événement le sera également
l'événement est gratuit je le rappelle
on peut réserver son billet coupe-file
gratuit sur le site billet web.fr ou
même pour pour certaines activités on va
désormais parler justement du cadre de
l'événement il est organisé donc au
domaine de Madame Elisabeth à Versailles
pourquoi avoir choisi le domaine de
Madame Elisabeth qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que ce lieu rend finalement cet
événement magnifique
j'ai envie de dire on est totalement
dans le cadre un parc de 8 hectares avec
son passé historique ma Isabelle petite
sœur de Louis XVI
sur le parc aucun produit chimique
depuis 15 ans une gestion différenciée
et donc on pense que voilà cette
thématique Flower Power est vraiment
dans la continuité de la gestion que le
département entreprend c'est à dire les
séparer la nature et voilà dans ce cadre
un peu champêtre au sein de Versailles
c'est surtout un très grand parc aussi
donc qui est accessible accessible à
tous est-ce que tout le parc sera
justement pris enfin l'organisation sera
surtout le tout le parc ou c'est
vraiment un lieu précis alors le la
manifestation sera autour de la demeure
avec la scène
les cours de Zumba seront dans le jardin
de l'Orangerie à proximité mais le parc
sera totalement ouvert sur ces 8
hectares pour la visite pour les
visiteurs qu'est-ce qui fait le charme
de du domaine de Madame Elisabeth selon
vous
la campagne à Versailles la campagne
voilà on est vous prenez le domaine du
château de Versailles qui est très grand
voilà avec cette dimension tourisme
international nous voilà on est un peu
en similaire puisque de toute façon ça
partait à la même famille mais à une
échelle beaucoup plus restreinte plus
intimiste c'est donc la troisième
édition en 2023 peut-on déjà parler
d'une quatrième édition en 2024 est-ce
que ce sera sur le la même thématique ou
est-ce que vous allez vouloir changer la
thématique alors absolument il y aura
une quatrième édition la Garden Party
fait enfin fait partie des événements
incontournables organisés par le
département des Yvelines sur la mettre
sur la thématique on verra si on garde
Flower Power ou si on se projette sur
une autre dimension et pour finir on va
parler un petit peu de vous en quelques
mots quelles sont vos ambitions au
quotidien sur le département des
Yvelines
alors nous services publics je pense que
chaque agent du département s'il
s'engagé dans cette collectivité c'est
pour rendre un service public
premièrement donc notre objectif c'est
de avec nos moyens avec notre budget et
avec nos bénévoles
c'est continuer à proposer des
événements publics sur le parc mais
également des événements privés qui
permettent ensuite de financer ces
événements publics et le prochain
événement public donc ce sera le 17 juin
au domaine de Madame Elisabeth à
Versailles pour la Garden Party merci
beaucoup Julien blutin d'avoir été avec
nous sur sensation pour plus
d'informations on peut se rendre sur le
site sortir yvelines.fr et pour revoir
ou réécouter cette émission rendez-vous
sur notre site et notre application
radio sensation
[Musique]